on 60 minutes last week Joe Biden was
asked whether he should have told his
son hunter not to take a seat on the
board of Ukrainian gas company verismo
he was already on the board and he's a
grown man and it turns out he did not do
a single thing wrong
that is not true hunter Biden was not
already on the board in early 2014 Vice
President Biden was put in charge of
Ukraine policy on April the 16th he met
with verismo board member Devin Archer
at the White House and two days later
after that his son Hunter joined the
company three days after that Biden went
to Ukraine and pushed for more gas
production and over the next two years
while hunter was on Burr isthmus board
his father who boasted on camera about
controlling US aid oversaw billions of
dollars that went to Ukraine including
to Ukraine's gas industry now we in New
York tonight and perhaps for that reason
my thoughts did turn to Rudy Giuliani if
you're watching mr. mayor I'd like to
stage what I think is known as an
intervention or as they call it at my
kids school in California eight redirect
if they do something wrong the teachers
redirect their behavior the president
says Rudy is a great corruption fighter
Rudy Giuliani's a vine man
he was the greatest mayor of the history
of New York and it's been one of the
greatest crime fighters and corruption
fighters so Rudy please can you redirect
your corruption investigation efforts to
focus on the real question we need
answers to how much US taxpayer aid went
to a Ukrainian company that was paying
Joe Biden's son while Joe Biden was in
charge of the aid that's the corruption
that's what needs to be investigated all
right so the reason I wanted to kind of
be clear about this redirecting is
because I feel other story on all of
this has got a bit murky and mud muddied
and firing the prosecution everything
there's a clear link here between widen
the aid and they're going to the gas
company weed but we don't know how much
money well there's a timeline and as you
know as I've been
critical the media is not pressing on
this I mean I applied on national TV my
journalist had an opportunity Nora
that's right she said didn't pick him up
exactly she didn't say anything but
there's an interesting phenomenon going
on I've been going to all the debates
and talking with Democratic voters they
care about this issue they think is
Shady
yes other candidates refuse to call them
out on this and it just is very
troubling to me because there's been
this kumbaya let's protect Uncle Joe
this is a primary doing the Republicans
there was a bloodbath anything that any
candidate had done any bit of corruption
anything it was Shady
they all went after each other and the
Democrats if they had any guts would go
after Joe Biden on 100 but because their
voters care about this yeah it's Shady
especially when you got Bernie Elizabeth
Warren they say that they want to fight
corruption and this is happening exactly
the reason why this matters because
everybody goes to the what about ISM
what about the Trump children what about
this this is why it matters because when
Joe Biden sat down and he did his very
first interview on Good Morning America
and he was asked what is your campaign
slogan going to be it was his first
interview coming into this race and he
said I'm going to make America moral
again he's going to restore integrity
right so he has made as the centerpiece
of his campaign that he's going to be
pristine that we have been that
president Trump is corrupt that he's
horrible he's a businessman he's trying
to make money left and right he's trying
to profit and lo and behold here he is
doing the exact thing he's accusing the
other person is doing if you make that
your centerpiece you're gonna choke on
your own moral fiber because without
question it's gonna be a let's play it
forward okay let we have you're focusing
on Ukraine and Purisima in this
situation right that's because it's in
part of the impeachment thing that'll
end at some point we'll have the
impeachment it'll all gonna go away no
one really thinks it's going to result
in a you know code to remove President
Trump from office so we'll move on then
it will be China the whole deal there
there's a lot to investigate there and
Joe Biden's brother and the contracts
for rebuilding Iraq or whatever it was I
mean there's endless in a material here
do exactly to that point sorry it's also
I don't think anyone actually believes
he wasn't aware that it
son was doing all these business
dealings that happen to coincide with
places that he was deeply involved in
occur a little bit smarter than that but
here's the thing too clearly the Joe
Biden campaign is concerned about the
optics here because if you follow the
actions of the campaign that I'll show
you that the fact that they're trying to
tell these television networks look you
shouldn't you shouldn't put Giuliani on
there trying to control the narrative
that sending letters to Google Twitter
Facebook demanding that they take down
ads about hunter Biden clearly there's
some concern there you look at them
attacking the New York Times for running
the op-ed by Peter SH wiser talking
about some of these very things or
looking at the fact that Joe Biden rolls
out this ethics pledge this whole like
ethics pledge saying that basically you
know this wouldn't happen under his
administration yet it happened come on I
mean gee your point that when he says we
never talked about it I mean are you
kidding me so you say son were you
working these days Ukraine it's not like
it's Detroit right I mean not everybody
works in Ukraine I think it would have
come up in conversation but the lies
continue because even after hunter Biden
won president Romney though where it's
hunter and Hunter magically appeared
again he said that he didn't know that
Hunter was released in a statement he
said he didn't know that hunter was
getting ready to give an interview that
is a lot that's not how campaigns work
there is a messaging strategy in typical
Michael especially I've got has been in
politics
the majority of